[Música]
[Aplausos]
te has preguntado que sería la vida sin
luz tal vez lo primero que piensan es no
voy a tener internet no voy a poder
conectar la computadora no voy a poder
cargar la batería del celular
pero esas serán las necesidades más
básicas de una familia que no tiene
acceso a la electricidad
la mayoría de las personas piensan que
eso es no tener luz el no poder tener el
no poder conectar un aparato electrónico
y el quedarse incomunicado y tal vez sí
pero han pensado que existen millones de
personas que mueren por la picadura de
un animal venenoso
o has pensado cuántos niños y niñas
hacen la tarea a la luz de la vela
inhalando los humos tóxicos o te has
imaginado tener que dejar de hacer tus
actividades diarias no porque se fue la
luz eléctrica sino porque se fue el luz
del día
en el mundo existen más de mil millones
de personas que no tienen acceso a la
electricidad
en méxico se estima que el 2.3 por
ciento de la población no cuenta con
acceso a la electricidad es decir cerca
de más de 2 millones de personas
esto impactando directamente en la
educación en la salud en la seguridad en
la productividad en la convivencia
familiar
la población más afectada por la pobreza
energética en méxico son las comunidades
indígenas comunidades que viven en
condiciones de pobreza y marginación son
las comunidades más aisladas las más
alejadas de servicios básicos y de
caminos principales
parece increíble que en pleno siglo 21
sigan viviendo comunidades y familias en
la oscuridad para muchas familias el
poder tener un foco led el poder tener
acceso a estas tecnologías implica
cruzar la frontera del atraso y de la
pobreza energética
sin embargo existen nuevas tecnologías
que permiten a muchas familias tener luz
por todo el día por primera vez
somos un grupo de jóvenes comprometidos
y que hemos podido llegar a donde nadie
llega que hemos podido trabajar con
estas comunidades
pero cómo comenzó la historia mi nombre
es liliana sánchez nací en el estado de
puebla siempre creí que estudiar era
para apoyar y ayudar a las poblaciones
más vulnerables
entonces empecé a investigar en donde
podía realizar este sueño y encontré un
programa de alfabetización donde
enseñaba a leer ya escribir a las
personas adultas viví durante seis meses
en una comunidad y fue donde conocí a
mariana una chica emprendedora que
estaba iniciando una empresa junto con
otros compañeros que estaban terminando
la carrera
y de ahí ellos lograron buscar
financiamiento y melo y me invitó
después me invitó a trabajar con ella
pero quiénes somos y lo méxico somos una
empresa que lleva energía solar a las
comunidades que no cuentan con este
servicio
pero como lo hacemos lo hacemos a través
de cuatro pilares de innovación el
primero tecnología mexicana nosotros
diseñamos y manufacturamos equipos que
se acondicione las a las necesidades de
las familias
distribución rural a través de los
centros que son sucursales que tenemos
ubicados en diferentes partes del país
para darle atención a estas comunidades
y lo más importante también creamos
empleos locales para jóvenes que tal vez
no tienen oportunidades o no hay foro no
hay trabajos dentro de sus zonas les voy
a contar una historia
eric a una chica indígena de la montaña
de guerrero estaba a punto de emigrar a
eeuu por la falta de oportunidades
dentro de su región
y ella creía que era la única forma de
poder salir adelante y de poder ayudar a
su familia pero tuvimos la fortuna de
conocerla y de invitarla a formar parte
de nuestro equipo ella inició siendo en
general comunitaria que son las personas
o los promotores de las comunidades pero
a ella ahora con su esfuerzo y con sus
ganas de seguir aprendiendo
ella es coordinadora estatal y
actualmente está estudiando una carrera
universitaria
otro pilar es la distribución real como
ya les había mencionado
y financiamiento flexible
sabemos que trabajamos con comunidades
de alta marginación por lo mismo
nosotros damos financiamiento a través
de créditos y de micro financiamientos
ella es doña paulina doña paulina es una
señora indígena del estado de durango
tiene poco que la conoce esta señora
está está muy pronto por terminar de
pagar su equipo solar
empoderamiento social creemos que es
importante involucrar la participación
de todos los miembros de la comunidad y
principalmente la participación de las
mujeres es por eso que creamos y diseña
diseñamos programas de educación
financiera de educación de medio
ambiente
lolo
esta es una historia que nos gusta mucho
compartir
lulú es una chica joven trabajadora de
la sierra mazateca
ella para poder para poder iluminarse
tenía que caminar más de dos horas de
ida y de vuelta para poder conseguir la
vela para poder conseguir el candil
pero nosotros llegamos a su comunidad y
ella decidió adquirir un equipo solar
con nosotros
actualmente lulu también logró poder
iluminar a más familias haciendo cuentas
dentro de su región ha iluminado a más
de 1.700 familias
lulú es un caso de éxito porque ella es
una mujer empoderada una mujer que ha
podido enfrentar la frontera de ser
mujer y de ser indígena
son muchas las historias que en méxico
podríamos contar
actualmente hemos beneficiado a más de
12.000 familias
pero sabemos que falta mucho faltan
muchas familias por iluminar
por eso creemos
que siempre será mejor cruzar las
fronteras de la marginación y la pobreza
energética para combatir la desigualdad
y las injusticias de construir muros y
cerrar fronteras muchas gracias
[Aplausos]